hello there fellow comrades
today we will take a look at the third
game from the first day of
the magnus sew final and
uh indeed this is a thrilling very
remarkable game
in a lot of different uh ways
i do think you will enjoy it i
definitely enjoyed it when i looked at
this game
a very very interesting and exciting
game let's see how it all went
down so magnus he started with um
he started with d4 knight f6 from wesley
c4 e6 magnus he keeps playing knight of
three
he uh he hasn't really been playing
knight c3 for quite some time i've
mentioned it quite a bit
this is the nimso indian
played a lot but he went for knight f3
d5
knight c3 and at this time wesley does
not play
c5 he did play that and
in the first game it didn't really
go as planned so instead he switched to
bishop b4
which is a very very interesting
line it's called aragosan this is also
what giri played
against magnus as well with great
success i might
uh i might add um as i've said before
this is the [ __ ] probably the other
main move here in this position
he takes c4 and bishop e7 as well played
frequently but c6 is
the most popular move if you do not
consider bishop before
all right and here magnus goes for queen
a4 which is known as a kind of a quiet
approach
a very solid line the point is that you
want to force black
to play knight c6 this is the only way
to defend the bishop
and the problem for black is that c5 has
become a lot harder now
so technically white weights attempt a
wastes tempo he is more or less forced
to play queen c2 at some point
but he makes black play knight c6 which
is quite beneficial
so the line here very often goes
something like
um bishop g5 i think this is the main
move
i've seen this uh quite quite a bit or
at least take on d5 first
probably e takes d5 and then bishop g5
this is known as some more of a solid
line here
takes takes e3 and this is very
extremely solid which is um
played a bit quite quite a bit but a3 is
the other move i believe also e3 here
is possible and we will put our queen on
c2 maybe develop with bishop d2
a3 bishop d3 take on d5 at some point
very very solid but magnus he plays a3
which is kind of more straightforward
uh this also more or less forces black
to take
if he plays bishop e7 here i think we
have a very nice position after
something like e3
and uh should be d2 rxe1
it really hurts black to have the knight
on on c6
so eventually decides to take which is
the logical approach
b takes c3 and simply castles so black
should try to make use of his
development advantage we notice that
white is struggling a little bit here he
hasn't castled yet or developed the
bishop
or the bishop on c1 as well while black
already has developed two knights
and he has already castled as well so
this does in a way make up for
the poorly placed knight on c6
magnus goes for bishop g5 pinning the
knight on f6 a very logical move
h6 well if you can play h6 you might as
well do it you've got a tempo while you
also get some
left for your king bishop h4
i should d7 i'm now threatening to take
on d4
with with the knight also even 95 in
some lines
so magnus goes back to c2
c65 would have been possible as well but
it was something like this
now knight 64 doesn't work because i can
take with my queen
but he plays queen c2 which is the other
move here
wesley decides to play knight a5 he
wants to play a c5
while he also wants a square on c4 with
his knight
but at at least c5 is the main way to go
here and play rook c8 and start
attacking against c3
and here magnus plays a remarkable move
a very very remarkable
uh move which is uh very surprising
it is certainly not completely out of uh
out of nowhere but it's a very
interesting move which could
potentially backfire or
it could be very clever it's
i have to put an interesting mark behind
the move because i don't think it's
objectively extremely good i don't think
it's bad
either i think it's like practically a
very good move and objectively
not such a good move so interesting is
probably the right the right way to put
it and that is the move g4 magnus simply
wants to open up the position here with
with g5 so here is the disadvantage when
you played
h6 you're always vulnerable to stuff
like
g4 g5 because you are forced to open up
the g file
if the pawn would have been on h7 g4
wouldn't have been doing
as much because you cannot open up the
the g
file because my pawn is on h7 not on h6
so maybe okay you get to play g5 but i
simply move my knight
and nothing really happens but when the
pawn is on h6 black is forced to take
and then it can become
slightly dangerous and i'm sure wesley
was quite scared because he answered
with g5
which is certainly saying that well
well well this is this was not uh
as harmless as i thought it was and it
certainly
g5 is certainly not the best move here
but it is kind of human to be
be scared of that of that g4 move
the best move is perhaps to simply grab
the pawn of dtx4 and i
very much understand why wesley why
wesley did not do it
it looks extremely scary to me to allow
g5 takes bishop takes and
practically speaking this is easy to
play for white while black is going to
have a tough time
so maybe this would have been the better
way to go and uh in a standard game in
blitz this is not so
not so easy because i'm going to play
rookie one and simply knight e5 and this
attack
is quite dangerous and bishop h6 in the
air it looks extremely unpleasant
which is certainly why i didn't go for
it the best move would have been here to
play bishop c6 and simply take the
knight as soon as possible
and we have a very complicated position
but that would have been
the way to go another move knight 64 is
uh is also possible but again i'm going
to play g5 take 6 and um
it's not so easy now because the
position is not open
you notice this diagonal here is no
longer open i'll play rook
rook g195 it's a lot easier to play
white
i might even have to say that g4 is a
good move now because it looks like an
extremely good move but practically
i mean it's not bad objectively either
so maybe i'll have to take my words back
and say
it is a good move objectively and
practically
all right but anyway this is a very
complicated
position which i think favors white due
to the fact that
uh the computer labor labors it as equal
and we are upon down and we have attack
so that that means that black needs to
be very precise
and um yeah so practically speaking what
would have been the best try for black
i mean i still think that d take c4 is
the way to go and bishop c6
grabbed the knight but um that is not so
fun so that is why wesley went for g5
which is
not very good due to the the problem is
that i'm going to play h4 and open up
the position even more and this is very
dangerous
but i'm sure wesley saw that well i can
play 94 and i get some compensation i
get quite
quite a lot of play and it's not so easy
for magnus well in a way that's true but
in another way it's not really that true
because
magnus simply ignores it it plays h4
anyway he is just going to open up
black's king
now that wesley takes on g3 i take back
it is looking very dangerous uh here i
am threatening to take on g5
so eventually is more or less forced to
to take
and i simply take with my rook look at
the attack already i have g5 coming
and look at how look at this queen
this is very very dangerous um so here
black
has a choice between knight 64 and king
g7 i think king g7 is the way to go
because rook h8
also is possible you don't really want
to give away that pawn although this is
certainly
not impossible you have to play f5 here
looks extremely scary and i would not be
surprised if this is lost but
you know that is it is playable
probably all right the king g7 is the
better
better move the magnus plays g5 which is
a logical
try he wants to simply open up the
position
certainly not a bad move another good
move is to play e4
take more space in the center but g5 is
good
rook h8 protecting the pawn and another
very good move this move is quite
important and that is the move95
and this has two points the first one
being that if i take back with the pawn
on g5 i will take on h8
queen takes h8 and then i take on d7
this is magnus's point
and you cannot take with the king
because of the fork and f7
and if i take with the queen i have rook
g4 winning
winning the queen but of course uh even
king f2 would have been strong here due
to the powerful attack but
you get my point rook g4 here simply
wins the queen
so it's not possible to take on g5 which
means that we are threatening to take on
h6
and probably the way to defend here is
to play queen e7
i think that is the best move also
because you
you are defending against threats like
rook four you can play rook f8
it's not extremely easy to break through
here but rook f6
like it's very dangerous and you have to
play bishop e8 in order to avoid
rook g6 mate even rook h7 it could be
possible but
i like bishop e8 and we have something
like queen c1
protecting g5 and this is a very
complicated position with queen f4
coming next and
it looks very very difficult practically
and
and wesley needs a miracle in order to
survive but he will survive if he finds
every accurate move here which is very
difficult
and he went for knight 64 which is the
other logical way to go you want to
you want to at least get some active
play but unfortunately for wesley's king
is all too weak
it takes king f8 simply take on a c4
it's not really the best move as you can
see on the evaluation bar right there
it is not the best way to go but it's
still a
quite a good move the best move would
have been to play queen c1 here
and the pla plan is simply to play h7
queen h6 uh as simple as that even queen
f4
if possible but h7 queen h6 is very
effective here
and it also prevents queen g5 which
could
create lots of counterplay for for black
so knight 64. queen g5 this is an
excellent resource
by wesley a very good move
this is his only chance really to stay
in the game if he takes back then
queen d2 with the same plan is very
effective and bishop g2
even long castle this is far far too
dangerous for him
for wesley so he played queen g5 which
is a good move
magnus plays king f2 i really like this
this move
the other movie here is 95 but after
takes king d2 queen xh4 knight 67
i think this is uh a lot more
complicated than it should be
and black has definitely compensation
objectively could be good for white but
i do not like this so i really like
magnus's approach here
king f2 he takes c4 queen c1
offering a queen trade an end game is
going to be very good of course due to
this amazing past pawn and this weak
pawn and
all of all of black's passive pieces so
that is out of the question for
wrestling plays queen of six check
queen f4 king e7
that is probably the way only way to go
i mean if it goes for queen takes f4
i'm probably going to take like this of
course i can't take with the rook the
pawn would be hanging and this is
this looks horrible for black maybe
again like queen e7 i simply play h7 or
even bishop g2 which is far too
dangerous so i like kinky seven
that is a logical attract queen takes f6
king takes f6 bishop g2 attacking on b7
rook b8 and rook h5 magnus
well he wants to double but he also gets
his rook in a on a better square here on
h5
also preventing sometimes c5 and e5
as well so i like that move too of
course something like e4 is
probably good but you have to you have
to see
what to do against d5 i'm sure magnus
didn't really
like it so that's why i played with h5
which i do like
king g6 stroke h1 f5
literally desperately tries for for some
activity here
g4 yet another really good move you
can't really take if you do i'll play
bishop b4
and simply h7 and this is always
completely losing due to this amazing
pawn in h7
i'm going to run up with my king and
yeah this is horrible all of his pawns
are too weak rook c5 is possible
at some point as well very very bad so
we're g7
preventing against that and g5 is
actually
quite inaccurate here surprisingly
enough it is very inaccurate as you can
see on the evaluation bar right there it
just went down tremendously
and it's very surprising that that is
the case i honestly think
it is a bit of an exaggeration but
the best move would have been simply to
play king g3
and if we see what happened in the game
here with bishop c6 i'll simply take
take take and take and then play
something like king f4
and i'm threatening to play rook g5 and
this position is completely
lost for for black for example rook b5
with g5
king f6 and then a4 rook a5
and then e4 completely winning
but in the in the game magnus play g5 so
bishop c6 was allowed
bishop f3 this is a good move it doesn't
really work anymore to take here
uh you can see that black has a nice
blockade here and it's not so easy to
get through because i'm going to play
rook b3 next and take these pawns
and it's quite unpleasant you notice a
big difference there
when i could take on f5 so g5 was a bit
too
too quick uh bishop f3 is better than
bishop takes c6 but
it's not so simple after bishop d5 the
road to victory here is not so simple
after something like e3 here and
yeah let's see i don't know good move
just simply wait with rook t8 or
whatever it's not so easy to get through
for for white so uh g5 was
far far too early it could have changed
the result of the game
quite a bit but taking the bishop is a
mistake i take back
rook d8 and now king f4 i perfectly
protect all of these pawns my king is
very safe and this is looking very very
bad for wesley
he needs to do something so he tries to
with rook d5
this makes things even harder the better
way to fight would be
c5 but simply e3 b5
you could try something like this but
it's not really going to end well with
these pawns here and at some point white
will crash through
but this would have been the only way to
to try
to have a chance at least but after rook
d5
rook h3 c5 rook
e3 rook d6 takes on c5
black's position simply crumbles and
after rook d1 who actually
even resigned the position is completely
lost so this was an
a remarkable game by the world champion
especially with the g4 move and
he simply played an he had a few
improvements like
for example queen c1 here would have
been even better but
all the time he just played a
magnificent magnificently all
all the way but just like the game of
chess
if you do not play perfectly you can
definitely
ruin it and g5 was a huge huge mistake
which could have changed
the game because after bishop c6 and
bishop d5 here
the position is very difficult to break
through
it really is hard to break through here
but this didn't happen
wesley missed his chance and then magnus
won
well deservingly i think wesley he
should have
he should have went for d take c4
after g4 but all honor to magnus g4 was
an excellent move
i wasn't so sure in the beginning but as
i started thinking a little bit more
he just i was just convinced so
excellent job
by wesley and well done
by magnus sorry by magnus
and the match stands uh
stands two-two so we'll be exciting to
see what
the 30th of november will bring
stay tuned